SUBCOMMITTEE UNTIL WE HAVE A
QUORUM.
TODAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MONIQUE
LIMON WILL BE REPLACING KEVIN
MULLIN.
AND WE WILL STE
START WITH. ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA YOU'RE
FREE TO OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED NEWS
CALIFORNIA'S VOLUNTARY TAX CHECK
OFF A HOUSE HYMERS RESEARCH AND
OTHER DEMENTIA RELATED DISEASES.
THE TAX CHECK OFF WAS FIRST
AUTHORIZED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN AS REYES OVER TWENTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS. BALL FUNDING
OVER A HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR
RESEARCH PROJECTS
WITHOUT RENEWAL OF THE FUND WILL
EXPIRE AND NOT APPEAR ON THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN STATE. TAX
FORM.
TODAY I ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE IS
THE THIRD LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH
IN CALIFORNIA WITH NO KNOWN
CAUSE CURE A PREVENTION.
AS MANY AS SIX HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS CURRENTLY
LIVE WITH THE DISEASE IN MORE
THAN ONE POINT SIX MILLION
FAMILY CAREGIVERS PROVIDE UNPAID
SUPPORT TO A LOVED ONE WITHOUT
TIMERS.
THE STATE WILL SPEND THREE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS THIS YEAR
ALONE ON MEDI CAL BENEFICIARIES
WITH THE CONDITION.
THE FUNDS FROM THE TAX CHECK OFF
PROVIDE RESEARCH THAT
ENCOMPASSES A SUCH AS BASIC LOVE
SCIENCE DIAGNOSIS TREATMENT DRUG
THERAPIES AND CARE GIVING TO
NAME A FEW.
MANY OF CALIFORNIA'S MAJOR
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE UNIVERSITIES
HAVE BEEN RECIPIENTS OF THIS
FUNDING AND THEY HAVE BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN ATTRACTING YOUNG
RESEARCHERS AND NEW SCIENTISTS.
TO THE FIELD OF ALZHEIMER'S
RESEARCH.
THE HUMAN AND ECONOMIC COSTS
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE AND RELATED
DEMENTIAS ARE STAGGERING.
MORE PEOPLE WITH ALZHEIMER'S
LIVING CALIFORNIA THAN ANY OTHER
STATE AND BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
THE NUMBER WILL GROW BY THIRTY
THREE PERCENT TO EIGHT. HUNDRED
AND FORTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
ALMOST THE SIZE THIS OF THE CITY
OF SAN JOSE.
THAT THE THIRD MOST POPULATED
SAYING THIS STATE THAT I
REPRESENT.
INVESTING IN RESEARCH TO FIND
THE CAUSE CARE PREVENTION FOR
THIS FATAL DISEASE BENEFITS EACH
AND EVERYONE OF US AND OUR
FAMILIES.
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS HAVE PROVEN
THEIR COMMITMENT THOUSAND AS
RESEARCH BY CONTINUOUSLY
SUPPORTING THE VOLUNTARY TAX
CHECK OFF SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN. BY CONSISTENTLY.
OF FULFILLING THE MINIMUM
THRESHOLD REQUIREMENT.
A I HAVE WITH ME TODAY DOCTOR
CHARLES TO CARLY TO TESTIFY ON
THIS IMPORTANT BILL AND
CERTAINLY ASK BUT I DON'T
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR'S
RECOMMENDATION
WHEN THIS ISN'T SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
CHAIRWOMAN AND MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
I WANT TO JUST TOUCH AND A
COUPLE OF VERY IMPORTANT POINT
BECAUSE IT WAS SO A WELL
ARTICULATED BY MY COLLEAGUE.
WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
AFFECTED BY THIS DISEASE ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT'S HAPPENING IN
AS WE ARE. SOCIETY GETS OLDER IS
IT'S BECOMING MORE DIVERSE AND
SO THE OTHER THING THAT WASN'T
TOUCHED ON BY MY COLLEAGUE. IS
THAT NOT ONLY ARE WE HAVING
MORE.
OLDER PEOPLE BUT MORE DIVERSE
OLDER PEOPLE AND WE DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE DIFFERENCE IS
BECAUSE THERE ARE DISPARITIES
LATINOS AND AFRICAN AMERICANS
ARE NEARLY TWICE AS LIKELY TO
GET A DEMENTIA. IN LATER LIFE.
THIS PROGRAM WHICH IS BE AND.
I THINK INCREDIBLY POPULAR WITH
CALIFORNIA VOTERS THAT'S NUMBER
THREE ON THE CHECK OFF LIST ON
AND IT REPRESENTS I THINK WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THE BABY BOOM
GENERATION. OF WHICH I AM A
MEMBER.
THAT.
BEYOND CANCER. ALZHEIMER'S AND
DEMENTIA ARE THAT IS NUMBER TWO
CONCERN OF THE BABY BOOM
GENERATION.
THESE CONTRIBUTIONS.
FACT
JUNIOR PEOPLE MOSTLY JUNIOR
RESEARCHERS AND SCIENTISTS AND
TO GET THEM STARTED. AND THAT'S
HOW CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
BUILD WOULD BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
TO BUILD THEIR RESEARCH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CONTINUED TO
BE I THINK THE LEADING INNOVATOR
IN ALZHEIMER'S AND DEMENTIA
RESEARCH IN THE COUNTRY IF NOT
IN THE WORLD. SO I CAN ONLY SAY
THAT I ABSOLUTELY AND
ENTHUSIASTICALLY.
SUPPORT THIS A CONTINUATION OF
THIS BILL IN ALL ITS FORMS AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M SUSAN TO MORRIS THE
STATE POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION WE'RE
PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS BILL AS WE
DID IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
WHEN IT WAS FIRST ENACTED. ON
WHERE PLEASE THAT IT'S REYES
NEARLY TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO DATE.
OUR ORGANIZATION'S VISION IS A
WORLD WITHOUT ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE AND THE WAY WE REALIZE
THAT VISION IS BY ACCELERATING
RESEARCH.
WERE PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND WE URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO VOTE AYE TODAY.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MONICA
MILLER BEHALF OF ALZHEIMER'S
GREATER LOS ANGELES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HEATHER HARRISON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSISTED LIVING
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
CHAPTER TO GEAR.
AS HAVING SEVERAL PEOPLE KNOWING
THAT I HAD SEEN THEM GOING
THROUGH THIS EXPERIENCE.
I WOULD APPRECIATE THAT THIS
CONTINUE TO BE SOMETHING THAT
WE'VE FIGURED OUT UNDERSTAND IT
SO MUCH BETTER.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
NINE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
A I JUST WANNA THANK OF THE
CHAIR OF THE I RECOMMENDATION
AND I CERTAINLY WANT TO THINK
ABOUT I'M ASSOCIATION FOR THEIR
PARTNERSHIP IN THIS CHAIR OF THE
ASIAN LONG TERM CARE COMMITTEE I
HOPE THAT THE MEMBERS OF. THE
COMMITTEE WILL SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
I'M I WOULD APPLAUD YOU ON YOUR
WORK ON THIS ISSUE AS SOMEONE IN
MY PREVIOUS LIFE I WORKED. ON A
IN A FINANCE CAPACITY WITH THOSE
WHO DO RESEARCH AND ALZHEIMER'S
DOCTORS WHO HAVE COMMITTED THEIR
LIVES TO AND SO. I AM REALLY
HAPPY TO SEE THIS AN HONOR TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR.
WITH THAT IS.
WITH THAT WE ARE STILL WORKING
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE SO. WHICH WILL
MAKE A RECOMMENDATION WILL BE DO
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS AND WE
WILL MOVE TO THAT. WE HAVE
A QUORUM THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN.
SERVICE.
BUT ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY
TWO FIFTY THREE.
SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR A. B. TWO
TWO FIVE THREE REMOVES A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR LIMIT FROM THE
CAL ABLE ACCOUNTS ALLOWING AN
INDIVIDUAL WITH DISABILITIES TO
SAVE MONEY FOR THE LONG TERM.
IN TAX IN A TAX EXEMPT A SAVINGS
ACCOUNT.
CURRENTLY CAL ABLE ACCOUNTS
ALLOW THESE INDIVIDUALS TO SAVE
MONEY WITHOUT AFFECTING THEIR
BENEFITS BUT ONLY IF THAT AMOUNT
IS UNDER A HUNDRED THOUSAND. IF
A FAMILY CAN SAVE OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO ASSIST A
DISABLED LOVED ONE THE
INDIVIDUAL WITH DISABILITY
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
LOSING THEIR LOCAL AND STATE
BENEFITS.
IN ADDITION CONSIDERING THE
CALIBER PROGRAM IS ABOUT TO
LAUNCH LATER THIS YEAR THIS
LIMIT MAY IMPACT ITS SUCCESS
THERE ARE THIRTY SIX STATES THAT
ALREADY HAVE CAL ABLE ACCOUNTS.
SOME OF THEM ACCEPT OUT OF STATE
IN ROWLEY'S AND NONE OF THEM
HAVE. LIMITS.
HAVE ANY LIMITS THIS BILL WILL
FURTHER SUPPORT CALIFORNIANS
WITH DISABILITIES AND ENSURE
THAT CAL THE KELLY WILL PROGRAM
IS EQUIPPED TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
WITH ME HERE IN SUPPORT TODAY IS
THE STATE TREASURER'S OFFICE.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARED MEMBERS ON
OF THE BLADE JOHNSON HERE ON
BEHALF OF STATE TREASURER JOHN
CHIANG.
TREASURER WHO THE CHAIR OF THE
CALIBER BOARD. AND THE SPONSOR
AB TWENTY FIFTY THREE LIKE TO
THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARE ONE
FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
AS STATED EARLIER AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY THREE ALLIANCE OUR STATE
LAW WITH FEDERAL LAW. BY
REMOVING THE HUNDRED OUT NOW
EXCLUSION CAP FOR STATE AND
LOCAL MEANS TESTED PROGRAMS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND ASSURES PARTICIPANTS THAT
THEIR ELDER BILLION THE NEWS
PROGRAMS WILL NOT BE NEGATIVELY
AFFECTED.
ADDITIONALLY BAR MOVING THE
CAPTAIN WOULD MITIGATE CONCERNED
ABOUT POTENTIAL PARTICIPANTS
WHO MAY BE RELUCTANT TO OPEN OR
CONTRIBUTE TO ENABLE ACCOUNT.
THEREFORE INCREASING
PARTICIPATION.
AND CONTRIBUTIONS IN THE CALIBER
PROGRAM.
WITH ME HERE IS DANTE ALLEN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIBER BOARD.
WHO CAN ADDRESS ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE THANK
YOU?
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
AS A RESOURCE ROOM DEPENDENT
LIVING. AND IS HAVING HEARD THIS
PROGRAM DEMONSTRATED. I'M I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THE DELAY BUT
PLEASE. LOOK FORWARD TO THIS
CONTINUING AND PLEASE GET THIS
BETTER OFF.
ADDITIONALLY ASSISTANCE SUPPORT.
TAKE YOUR TIME.
EVELYN I WASN'T DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WERE ACROSS
DISABILITY ORGANIZATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THINKING.
TERESA ANDERSON WITH OUR
COMMUNITY P. CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA CORTES ROTH ON BEHALF OF
AUTISM SPEAKS IN THE CENTER FOR
AUTISM AND RELATED DISORDERS AND
SPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON VERY JUTTING FROM
THE CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
SERVICES ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
THANK.
CONNIE BOYER FRENZEL WITH AUTISM
SOCIETY CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
ABOUT TEN CHAPTERS WHO I'M.
THEY'RE SUPPORTING THIS ALSO
AUTISM SOCIETY AN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA AND ALSO STATE COUNCIL AND
CAN LIKE GIVE JUST A PERSONAL
WHY I'D LIKE TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL. IS THAT OKAY.
SURE OKAY WHEN. I'VE DONE THIS
TOO MUCH.
SO I'M A PARENT.
OF MY SON MAKES ABOUT NINE
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH COMBINED
PLEASE TALK TO STICK THIRTY.
COMBINED WITH HIS S. SOCIETY AND
MY FAIRLY MEAGER SOCIAL
SECURITY.
HE LIVES IN MILPITAS ARE YOU
KNOW SILICON VALLEY NO WAY CAN
HE LIVE ON NINE HUNDRED DOLLARS
A MONTH OR.
LIST ANYBODY THERE AND SO THAT'S
WHY I REALLY FEEL THAT I'D LIKE
TO STRETCH OUT THE MONEY OVER
MANY YEARS HOPEFULLY YOU KNOW
AND AFTER I DIE I DON'T HAVE TO
WORRY THAT HE'S GONNA GO WITH
ABJECT POVERTY IN THAT'S WHY DID
COACH PLEASE.
TAKE THAT WOMEN AWAY THINKING.
FOR BEING HERE.
WITNESSES AT ALL OAK ADDITIONAL
ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT.
THE LOWER.
HI I'M JANE WORN. I'M A FORMER
BOARD MEMBER OF SAN FRANCISCO
BOARD OF DIRECTORS AND ALSO
FORMER INTERPRETIVE AT TAFT.
I ALSO AM THE MOTHER OF TWO SONS
WITH AUTISM. I WAS LUCKY I GOT
THE LOTTERY TWICE.
AND.
.
BOTH OF MY SONS THEIR OF THEIR
GROWN. AND THEY LIVE ON ABOUT
NINE HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH
THEY ALSO LIVE ON TREASURE
ISLAND.
IT'S NOW IS VERY TOXIC AND
TRYING THEY'RE TRYING TO REMOVE
THE TOXIC DUMPS LIKE THAT IT HAD
BECOME. AND THE REDEVELOPING IT
HOWEVER THEY'RE NOT WE
DEVELOPING IT FOR THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE THERE. THAT HAVE
DISABILITIES OR SECTION EIGHT
HOUSING.
THAT'S STILL UP IN THE AIR. MY
FEAR IS THAT LAW.
ONCE WE PASSED AWAY.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE LIVING. IN
A TENT ON THE STREET BASICALLY.
.
THIS IS A GREAT GREAT CONCERN TO
MY HUSBAND LICENSE FOR BOTH NOW
IN OUR SEVENTIES.
SO.
WE DO HAVE A SPECIAL NEEDS
TRUST BUT.
IT'S THAT WOULD REQUIRE HIM TO
GO TO THE EXECUTOR EVERY TIME WE
NEED TO NEW PAIR SHOES.
THIS WOULD GIVE HIM THE DIGNITY
OF WITHDRAWING ENOUGH MONEY TO
BUY CLOTHING. A.
I HAIRCUT.
BECAUSE THE MONEY THAT THEY'RE
GIVING HIM FROM THE STATE IS NOT
ENOUGH FOR HIM TO EVEN GO TO A
MOVIE.
SO ARE HOPING TO BE ABLE TO PASS
THIS BILL.
AND
SUPPORT MARK ARE SOUNDS.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
YES A GOOD AFTERNOON.
.
FRED BOLDLY FROM THE AUTISM
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION. AND WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL TO HELP.
THESE PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
I'M ALSO BEEN HELPING CHILDREN
WITH AUTISM FOR CLOSE TO THIRTY
YEARS IN THE BAY AREA PROVIDING
SERVICES.
AND I SEE SO MANY OF THESE
FAMILIES OVER THE YEARS
STRUGGLING TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO HELP THEIR CHILDREN.
IN ADDITION I HAVE NEEDS WITH
DOWNS WAS FORTY YEARS OLD. WHO
IS ALSO IN THE SAME SITUATION
AND TRYING TO?
PER FAMILY OUR FAMILIES TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN
CONTINUE TO TRY TO HELP HER. IN
HER SITUATION.
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
WHEN WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET
BUT THE RECOMMENDATION WILL BE
DO PASSED APPROPRIATIONS.
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR.
MANY MEMBERS.
SO WE WERE HOLDING.
SO I AND NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTY THREE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDING YOU MAKE
OF.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AS A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE TO PRESENT.
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY THREE TO
YOU TODAY.
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY THREE WOULD
EXTEND THE SUNSET DATE FROM
JANUARY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TO JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. ON CURRENT LAW
WHICH EXCLUDES REBATES. AND
VOUCHERS ISSUED BY LOCAL WATER
AGENCY FOR PARTICIPATION AND
TURF REMOVAL WATER CONSERVATION
PROGRAM FROM GROSS INCOME.
AS OF MARCH SIXTH TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. ABNORMAL DRYNESS OR
DROUGHT WAS AFFECTING NINETY
EIGHT PERCENT OF CALIFORNIA
POPULATION.
WE MUST CONTINUE TO USE OUR
WATER CAREFULLY. THIS CONTINUED
INCENTIVE WILL ENCOURAGE FUTURE
PARTICIPATION IN PROGRAMS WITH
THE END GOAL OF INCREASING WATER
COP CONSERVATION IN CALIFORNIA.
WE MUST CONTEND WITH THAT. I
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND.
LOOK FORWARD TO.
SENATE REMOVAL.
ADDITIONAL.
SUPPORT YEAH.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE ROSS ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF PASADENA
THIS IS A PROGRAM WE HAVE HAD
THE CITY IT'S BEEN SUCCESSFUL.
IT'S RAISED A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF TIME OR I SHOULD SAY CONCERT
THE SIGNIFICANT SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF WATER WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT PROGRAM TO CONTINUE
AND THAT'S THE GREAT BELT SO
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON READY THOMPSON
WITH MUCH PELTON WATER DISTRICT
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
ALSO IN SUPPORT WE BELIEVE BY
EXTENDING THE SUNSET DATE IT
WILL INCREASE PARTICIPATION. IN
CONSERVATION PROGRAMS SUCH AS
TRUST TURF REMOVAL WHICH WOULD
LEAD TO WATER SAVINGS THROUGHOUT
OUR REGION IN PARTICULAR AS WELL
AS THROUGH OUT THE STATE THANK
YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
NONE WHILE WE HAVE ACCORDING TO
PAUSE FOR ONE MOMENT WELL WE
HAVE A QUORUM COMMITTEE THROW.
BURKE HERE.
GROW.
ALLEN.
BONTA.
CHU GRAY MCCARTY.
LENDERS.
LOW MOAN.
QUIRK HERE.
THEY HAVE.
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
OF.
MOTION FROM PEROT SECOND FROM
LIMON.
TO A CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I HOPE.
TAKE A FRIEND TAKE A VOTE.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE BURKE
AYE ROW. ROW AYE ALLEN. BONTA
CHU GRAY MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S.
RELIGIOUS AYE LEMOND.
LOW MOAN AYE QUIRK AYE.
SPIRITS.
SIX ZERO SUPPLIES OUT. BREAK.
CLICK.
OKAY.
WHO IS SECOND?
WE'RE JUST GONNA TAKE A VOTE
REAL QUICK AND I WANT TWENTY
AFTER SO A GOOD ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY THREE
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PRO A SECOND
FAMILY MON.
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE AYE
BURKE AYE GROW. GROW AYE ALLEN
BONTA CHU.
GRAY MCCARTY.
PRETTY AYE MELENDEZ. MULLIN JUST
AYE LOW MOAN.
LOW MOAN AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
THE BILL'S OUT TO BILLS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED.
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM BORROWER
SECOND FAMILY. THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE BURKE
AYE BROUGH. ROW AYE ALLEN BONTA.
CHU GRAY MCCARTY.
CORDY I MELINDA'S SIDE ALLEGES
AYE LOW MOAN.
THE MOAN AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
BILLS UPSIX THERE. THE BILL'S
OUT ITEM NUMBER TWO AB TWENTY
ONE THIRTY ONE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MELINDA'S WHICH
ELECT OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MADAM
CHAIRWOMAN I'M HERE TO PRESENT
AB TWO ONE THREE ONE I WOULD
LIKE TO START BY SAYING THAT I
WILL BE TAKING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS.
AFTER THE PAST EIGHT YEARS CO
MAGAZINE IS RIGHT CALIFORNIA THE
WORST PLACE TO DO BUSINESS. BILL
BEFORE YOU TODAY WILL PROVIDE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES A SMALL
BUT MUCH NEEDED TAX RELIEF. BY
CUTTING THE MINIMUM FRIENDS TYPE
FRANCHISE TAX IN HALF.
THE MINIMUM FRANCHISE TAX TO
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENTLY THE
HIGHEST IN THE NATION EIGHT
HUNDRED DOLLARS. COMPARED TO
FIFTY DOLLARS IN ARIZONA OR
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS IN OREGON.
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
RECENTLY REPORTED THAT REDUCING
THIS TAX WOULD PROVIDE TAX
RELIEF AN ECONOMIC INCENTIVE TO
BUSINESSES IN THIS STATE.
THIS WOULD ARE CALIFORNIA WOULD
GAIN MORE FROM ENCOURAGING
ENTREPRENEURS TO OPEN A BUSINESS
AND HIRE EMPLOYEES THAN ANY
REVENUE LOST FROM THIS MINIMUM
FRANCHISE TAX EXEMPTION. HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
SHAUN LOWEST FROM THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION OF INDEPENDENT
BUSINESSES AND WE PATTERSON WITH
CAPITAL LEGAL INVESTIGATION AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HI SHAUN LUIS WITH THE NFIB
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING OVER
TWENTY THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS IN CALIFORNIA. A SMALL
INDEPENDENT BUSINESSES IN ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
BUSINESSES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
IN SUPPORT AS AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY ONE BUT PROVIDE IMMEDIATE
DIRECT FINANCIAL RELIEF TO
THOUSANDS OF OUR MEMBERS AND
MANY MANY MORE. A BUSINESSES IN
GENERAL ACROSS THE STATE JUST A
COUPLE QUICK POINTS OUT WHAT WE
DO KNOW IS THAT SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS DO DRIVE THE CALIFORNIA.
AND UNITED STATES ECONOMY AND
CALIFORNIA NINE NINE POINT EIGHT
PERCENT OF ALL BUSINESSES ARE
SMALL BUSINESSES AND HALF OF ALL
EMPLOYEES ARE EMPLOYED BY A
SMALL BUSINESS SO. THIS BILL
WOULD PROVIDE BENEFIT AND RELIEF
TO THOSE.
SMALL INDEPENDENT BUSINESSES
ABOUT SIXTY PERCENT OF OUR
MEMBERS.
FILE AS PASSED AT PASS THROUGH.
AB BUSINESSES SO IT WOULD
BENEFIT THEM GREATLY.
AND WE FIND THAT OUR MEMBERS
TELL US THIS ANNUAL EIGHT
HUNDRED DOLLAR MINIMUM FRANCHISE
TAX.
JUST FOR THE PRIVILEGE OF DOING
BUSINESS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CAN BE VERY COST
PROHIBITIVE SO FOR SOME MAY SAY
IT WOULD BE A SLIGHT BENEFIT.
OUR MEMBERS TELL US WOULD BE
SIGNIFICANT BENEFIT AND WE
BELIEVE IN OUR MEMBERS BELIEVE
THAT TAX POLICY SHOULD BE A
REFLECTION OF OUR.
PRIORITIES AND WHEN MY MEMBERS
CALL AND ASK ME HOW CAN
CALIFORNIA AFFORD HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN TAX
BREAKS FOR BIG MOTION PICTURE OR
BIG SOLAR. CAN'T WE PROVIDE THIS
MODEST TAX RELIEF TO THE ENGINE
OF OUR ECONOMY OUR SMALL
BUSINESS JOB CREATORS WE HOPE SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM A SIMILAR
ALLEN IN THE SECOND FROM BRO.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
JENNIFER TANNAHILL ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ENROLLED AGENTS MANY ENROLLED
AGENTS HAVE A CLIENTS WITH VERY
TINY NEW BUSINESSES AND THIS
BILL WOULD I HOPE THAT GET THOSE
BUSINESSES OFF THE GROUND SOBRE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WHEN HE'S IN OFFICE THOSE ARE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LUKE PATTERSON I'M WITH CAPITAL
LEGAL INVESTIGATIONS I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LICENSED
INVESTIGATORS. FOR TWELVE
HUNDRED INVESTIGATORS THEIR
MEMBERS A TALLY. ALMOST ALL OF
THEM ARE SMALL BUSINESS PEOPLE.
AND THIS REDUCTION IN THE
FRANCHISE TAX WOULD BE SMALL BUT
STILL WELL APPRECIATED AND MAY
HELP SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES MOVE
FROM BEING A SOLE OPERATOR. INTO
THE CORPORATE WORLD.
THINK YOU WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
DANIELLE CANADA BECAUSE OUR ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA TAX
REFORM ASSOCIATION WE ARE STILL
REVIEWING THE SPELL BUT WE DO
ANTICIPATE. AND OPPOSE POSITION
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THE ARTWORK.
BOB I JUST DON'T KNOW WHERE WE
FIND A REPLACEMENT FOR THE SIX
OR SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
THAT THIS BILL PASSES.
UNLESS I CONCEDE THAT I DON'T
SEE HOW I CAN VOTE FOR IT.
THAT THERE'S A SIX TO SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR ESTIMATE
FROM THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
WHAT THIS COSTS.
IS IT A QUESTION ARE YOU ASKING
ME WHERE IT'S COMING FROM HER.
IF YOU HAVE ANY.
IDEA ON HOW WE MIGHT MAKE UP
THAT MONEY.
I I KNOW THE GOVERNOR WILL
INSIST ON AN APPROPRIATION IN
THE BUDGET.
WHICH WOULD BE TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY MILLION FOR THIS YEAR
SIX HUNDRED MILLION THE NEXT
YEAR SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION.
HERE.
UNLESS WE CAN NEED TO FIND A WAY
TO REPLACE IT OR MAKE AN
APPROPRIATION IN THE BUDGET.
I JUST DON'T SEE HOW THIS BILL.
.
I CAN SUPPORT THIS BILL.
WELL.
I'D APPRECIATE YOUR CANDOR ON
THE BALLOT I KNOW YOU DON'T
TYPICALLY SUPPORT BILLS LIKE
THIS.
SO YOU'RE CERTAINLY NOT.
BREAKING WITH HISTORY I JUST
WILL SAY THAT.
.
THE MORE WE ENCOURAGE BUSINESSES
TO EXAND IN CALIFORNIA THE MORE
TAX REVENUE THAT CALIFORNIA WILL
SEE AND THE MORE PEOPLE WHO ARE
GOING TO WORK THE BETTER THAT
IS.
FOR CALIFORNIA SO I THINK IT'S
EASY FOR US TO GET INTO
GOVERNMENT MINDSET OF. M. IF
YOU'RE. IF YOU TAKE THIS AMOUNT
OF MONEY FROM YOUR CITIZENS.
AND THEN YOU STOP TAKING THAT
IN MY MONEY DON'T REPLACE IT
WITH SOMETHING SOMEHOW THAT'S
TAKING MONEY FROM US AND IT'S
NOT IT'S TAKING IT FROM THE
BUSINESS OWNERS. AND FROM THE
EMPLOYEES AND I. AM IT'S JUST A
DIFFERENT WAY LOOKING AT IT SO
DO I HAVE ANYTHING IDENTIFIED.
SPECIFICALLY WHERE A
REPLACEMENT.
THE GROWTH IN THE BUSINESS
SECTOR OF THE ECONOMY
PARTICULARLY IN THE SMALLER
BUSINESS SECTOR WHO. THE WHEN HE
SAYS YOU KNOW HAVE TESTIFIED
THAT THIS IS A BIG DEAL FOR THEM
NOT MAYBE AS MUCH FOR BIG
BUSINESS BUT CERTAINLY FOR SMALL
ONE.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER A SOLAR ALLEN I THINK
IS A NINETY.
LIKE I SAID WE.
ZERO ZERO.
WATER CO ZERO.
WELL I'M TRYING TO BE OPTIMISTIC
AND WHAT I CAN ACCOMPLISH HERE
TODAY BUT PERHAPS NEXT YEAR THIS
BILL GETS THROUGH WE CAN DO
THAT.
FORCING.
ZERO.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER ALLEN FOR YOUR
OPTIMISM.
I.
BOB I WOULD LIKE TO SAY I
UNDERSTAND THAT OBVIOUSLY THIS
BILL HAS A A HIGH HIGH BECAUSE
THEY DO ALSO APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT SMALL BUSINESSES STARTING
OUT COULD USE ALL THE HELP THEY
CAN THEY CAN GET AND THEY ARE
OUR LARGEST EMPLOYER SO.
WITHOUT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
UP I WOULD JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NINE A THINK YOU.
ALRIGHT THE MOTION IS.
DO PASS AS AMENDED
APPROPRIATIONS THE AMENDMENT IS
A FIVE YEAR SUNSET.
THE COURT WILL BLOW.
MUCH AS DO PASSABLY MANAGED TO
APPROPRIATIONS PARK BY BURKE AYE
BRO. BRO I ALAN. ALLEN AYE
BONTA.
CHU GRAY MCCARTY.
MCCARTY NOT VOTING MELINDA'S.
LYNN JUST AYE LIMON.
LOW MOAN AYE QUIRK NOT VOTING
QUIRK NOT VOTING IT IS.
ON CALL IT NEEDS ONE.
THAT'S A CALL IT'S MORE ABOUT.
WOMEN ITEM NUMBER ONE AB TWENTY
THIRTY NINE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PHONE TWO LIKE TO
OPEN
.
I.
EMAIL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
I'D LIKE TO START OFF BY SAYING
FIRST I ACCEPT THE FIVE YEARS
SINCE AN AMENDMENT ON THE BILL
PER THE COMMITTEE'S REQUEST. I
AM PLEASED AT THE PRESENT AB
TWENTY THIRTY NINE WHICH WILL
PROVIDE A STATE TAX DEDUCTION TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO CONTRIBUTE TO
CAL ABLE SAVINGS ACCOUNTS
BENEFITING INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES. THIS BILL WILL
GREG CALIFORNIANS WHO CONTRIBUTE
TO CAL ABLE SAVINGS ACCOUNTS A
STATE TAX DEDUCTION FOR THE FULL
AMOUNT OF THEIR CONTRIBUTION.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN CONGRESS
PASSED THE ACHIEVING A BETTER
LIFE ACT WHICH ENABLES
INDIVIDUALS WITH WITH THIS
ABILITIES TO OPEN TAX ADVANTAGE
SAVINGS ACCOUNTS.
THE PASSAGE OF ABLE RECOGNIZE
THE CHALLENGES OF LIVING WITH A
DISABILITY AND ASSOCIATED COSTS
BY GIVING INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES A BETTER CHANCE AT
FINANCIAL INDEPENDENCE NOW YOU
SAY OPERATE THEIR OWN ABLE
PROGRAMS. AND MANY CALIFORNIANS
HAVE ALREADY OPENED ACCOUNTS AND
OTHER STATES.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE OFFER
INCENTIVES SO THAT CALIFORNIANS
WITH DISABILITIES AND THEIR
LOVED ONES CAN CONFIDENTLY
CONTRIBUTE TO THEIR OWN
FINANCIAL STABILITY AND SECURE
BETTER FUTURES.
THIS BILL WILL HELP PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES IN THEIR FAMILY'S
PREPARE FOR THE FUTURE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THESE ACCOUNTS
ARE IMPORTANT STEP IN GIVING
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES A
CHANCE AT INDEPENDENCE. THIS
BILL HAS BROAD SUPPORT INCLUDING
THE CALIFORNIA STATE TREASURER
JOHN CHIANG AND NINETEEN
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE DISABILITY
COMMUNITY WITH ME TODAY. TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIBER PROGRAM
DOT TO ALAN AND DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
ACTOR CARRIE FISHER STUFF.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON ON BEHALF OF
KELLY WILL I WANNA OFFER SINCERE
THANKS TO SOME WOMEN WERE FONG
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP IN SUPPORT OF
CALLEVA INFERENTIAL DO SAYING.
AB TWENTY THIRTY NINE.
OF THIS LEGISLATION REPRESENTS A
STRONG INCENTIVE FOR FAMILY AND
FRIENDS TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE IN
SUPPORT. OF FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
NO WE STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT OF
THIS WILL SERVE AS A POWERFUL
INCENTIVE.
AND AS YOU HEARD FROM THE
PREVIOUS TESTIMONY ON TWENTY TWO
FIFTY THREE.
THAT THIS IS MUCH NEEDED FOR A
COMMUNITY THAT IS OFTEN.
UNDERSERVED.
OFTEN AMONG THE HIGHEST IN
UNEMPLOYMENT OR UNDEREMPLOYMENT.
AND.
EIGHT. TAX.
CREDIT FOR FOLKS THAT WOULD
SUPPORT. THOSE PEOPLE I THINK IS
IS WHAT DO.
TO SHOW INNOCENCE IN SUPPORT.
HI CONNIE BOYER FRENZEL AGAIN IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND I JUST
WANNA TELL YOU A FEW REASONS
WHY.
OF. I WAS A FORMER COUNTY PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSE.
AND I WILL NOT A HUGUENOT ON
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS SO I WANT TO
STRETCH THE MONEY OUT THIS WE
WILL BILL WORKS BETTER THAN A
SPECIAL NEEDS TRUST A SPECIAL
NEEDS TRUST. COSTS A LOT TO
ADMINISTER TO START UP AND IT
WILL ALLOW.
PEOPLE WHO CAN ACTUALLY CONTROL
THEIR FINANCES MORE IN THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY TO DO THAT
THEY CAN TAKE MONEY IN AND OUT.
AND IT WILL ALLOW MY SON WHO IS
CONSERVED FOR ME TO STRETCH THE
MONEY OUT.
AND THEN I SAW COMMON IN THERE
THAT'S IT WILL MAYBE IT'LL
INCOGNITO ONE HELP PEOPLE.
SHIRLEY DONATE MORE TO CAL ABLE
ABSOLUTELY IF I CAN GET A TAX
SLIGHT TAX ADVANTAGE I CAN
SPREAD THAT MONEY OUT OVER THE
YEARS. AND SO IT JUST MAKES
FINANCIAL SENSE BECAUSE AS SAID
BEFORE WE DON'T WANT TO SEE OUR
CHILDREN ENDING UP INTENSE
AND SOME OF THE BAR ALREADY
HOMELESS IN SAN FRANCISCO WITH
REGIONAL CENTER SUPPORTING THEM
SO WE REALLY AS. AS PARENTS AND
FAMILY MEMBERS WE NEED SOME HELP
NOT ALL OF US ARE MILLIONAIRES
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM ALLEN IN A
SECOND FROM BRO.
SOMEONE.
PLEASE HOPE FOR. ME HERE.
COLLEGES.
IT EVELYN I'M HAASAN'S
INDOLOGISTS AT ABOUT IT WOULD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
THIS INCENTIVIZE IS
CONTRIBUTIONS AND ALLOWS PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES TO HAVE THE
MONEY TO SPEND ON THE THEIR
MEDICAL NEEDS AND OTHER THINGS.
WE ARE VERY STRONG SUPPORT ANNA
LOOK FORWARD TO HELPING AS THE
BILL MOVES. THINKS.
TRUTH ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE
ARK IN UCP CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION AND SUPPORT.
VERY GETTING WITH CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SERVICES ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT.
IF A FOOTBALL THE FROM THE
AUTISM BUSINESS ASSOCIATION.
STRONG SUPPORT AND ALSO FROM
BEHAVIORAL INTERVENTION
ASSOCIATION WORKING WITH OUR
CHILDREN TALK TO THEM A FOUNDER
OF THIS NONPROFIT.
HE SERVED BOTH CHILDREN AND
FRESNO COUNTY IN THE BAY AREA
AND MANY MANY OF THE FAMILIES WE
HAVE SERVED WOULD. SINCERELY. BE
OVERJOYED BY THIS BILL THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
MELISSA CORTES ROTH ON BEHALF OF
AUTISM SPEAKS AND THE CENTER FOR
AUTISM AND RELATED DISORDERS IN
SUPPORT.
HI AGAIN MY NAME IS JAN WARREN.
I REALLY LIKE TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
BECAUSE AFTER MY HUSBAND AND I
ARE GONE. BOTH OF US BEING IN
OUR SEVENTIES SUNKEN TO BE THAT
LONG. OUR SON'S DO HAVE A
SPECIAL NEEDS TRUST.
BUT THAT'S A VERY EXPENSIVE
SITUATION AND EVERY TIME HE
WITHDRAWS MONEY IT MAY AFFECT
HIS SAYS SECURITY.
AND HIS MEDICAID WITCHY BOTH OF
THEM DESPERATELY NEED BECAUSE
THEY HAVE DUAL DIAGNOSIS.
A WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THEM EVEN AFTER WORK ON.
WE HAVE TO SUPPORT THEM UNTIL
THEY'RE GONE.
AND THAT'S THAT'S A VERY BIG
WORRY FIRST
FOR US AS PARENTS.
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
DOT QUIRK.
SO BOB I CERTAINLY I RESPECT THE
NEEDS OF THE.
COMMUNITY. UNFORTUNATELY WITH
THIS BILL DOES IS GIVES THE PATH
THEY MOST OF THE BENEFIT TO THE
PEOPLE WHO MAKE THE MOST MONEY.
AND ALMOST NO BENEFIT TO PEOPLE
WHO MAKE VERY LITTLE MONEY.
IF YOU'RE MAKING.
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND A YEAR FOR
EXAMPLE YOU GET TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS BACK.
BUT IF YOU'RE MAKING A MILLION
DOLLARS YEAR YOU GET THIRTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS BACK.
SO THE DIFFICULTY HERE IS SIMPLY
THAT MOST OF THE BENEFIT GOES TO
THE HIGHER INCOME OWNERS.
I WOULD RESPECT ABILITY THE SAME
PRICE SIX MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
ROUGHLY.
IF IT. GAVE MOST OF THE MONEY
TO THE PEOPLE WHO MADE LESS
MONEY. AND NO MONEY TO ANYONE
WHO SAY MADE MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND YEAR. UNDER
THIS SPELL SOMEBODY MAKING FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND HERE WOULD GET
THE TEN TEN PERCENT OR TEN
THOUSAND DOLLAR.
.
IT'S YOU MEAN NAY DAY.
SAVE THE FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
THEY COULD GET A TEN THOUSAND
DOLLAR BENEFIT. I JUST DON'T
THINK THAT'S EQUITABLE.
BUT AGAIN IF YOU COULD COME
BACK WITH THE BILL WHERE MOST OF
THE MONEY WENT O LOW INCOME
INNER EARNERS I COULD CERTAINLY
SUPPORT IT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
JUDGE BECAUSE I WOULD WHICH IS
ONLY A HOLLOW ONCE AGAIN.
MISTER BONTA KEY SPEAKING MR
MCCARTY IS A MICROPHONE FOR
RIGHT NOW.
SURE.
.
JUST A A CLARIFYING QUESTION ARE
THERE ANY OTHER AREAS WHERE WE
GIVE SORT OF THAT THAT THE
DOUBLE TAX.
ADVANTAGE.
THAT'S BEING PROPOSED HERE AND
AND.
MY UNDERSTANDINGS THAT THAT
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT UNIQUE ARE
MAYBE UNPRECEDENTED. AND ALSO.
WHAT IS THE BEHAVIORAL CHANGE?
THAT YOU ANTICIPATE WHAT WILL
HAPPEN BECAUSE OF THIS BILL THAT
WHAT WHAT ARE PEOPLE NOT DOING
BUT BECAUSE OF YOUR BILL TO ALL
THE STUDY BE. INCENTIVE TO DO OR
WILL START DOING.
BUT WE CERTAINLY WANT A SET OF
FIVE AS MANY CALIFORNIANS TO
SAVE.
AS POSSIBLE FOR THE SPECIALLY
FOR THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS.
WHO ARE WHO HAVE WHO HAVE NEEDS?
DO THEIR DISABILITIES.
.
SO IF IT DID THE DOUBLE TAXATION
ARGUMENT AYE AYE IS IS IS THE
ONE THAT'S OUT THERE BUT WHEN WE
ONE INCENTIVIZE NOT ONLY JUST
INDIVIDUAL BUT THEIR FAMILIES AS
WELL SO. THE I THE UNCLE THE
MOTHER THE FATHER THEY DON'T
THEY DON'T GET A DEDUCTION AT
THE MOMENT SO HOW WE WON
INCENTIVIZE THOSE INDIVIDUALS TO
SAVE AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE FOR THE
FUTURE OF THEIR CHILDREN. OR
FAMILY MEMBERS.
I WOULD ALSO ADD TO THAT THAT
THERE IS A.
THE VET.
THEY'RE TWO SIDES TO THIS SO
THERE'S THAT TAX ADVANTAGE
PORTION FOR THE BENEFICIARY SO
IT LOOKS THAT.
VERB THAT EARNINGS ON INTEREST
FROM INVESTMENTS.
AT THAT IS RELATIVELY.
THAT MAYBE RARE IN MOST CASES
THE WAY THAT THAT ABLE ACCOUNTS
WORK THEY'RE VERY TRANSACTIONAL.
AND SO MOST MANY FOLKS WHO USE
IT MAY NOT INVEST FOR LONG TERM
EARNINGS ON THAT SO. BUT EVEN IF
THEY DID THAT BENEFIT WOULD GO
TO THE BENEFICIARY THE OWNER OF
THE ACCOUNT WHEREAS FOR THIS
BILL IT LOOKS AT THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE CONTRIBUTING FOR THE
ACCOUNT.
AND SO WE WANT TO INCENTIVIZE
THOSE INDIVIDUALS TO CONTRIBUTE.
REALLY FOR THE INDEPENDENCE AND
WELL BEING.
OF THE BENEFICIARY.
UP TO A CLOSE. I SUSPECT WE ASK
RIVA.
AND THE ACTUAL TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS THE
AMENDMENT IS TO ADD A FIVE YEAR
SUNSET ARE YOU ACCEPTING THAT I
ACCEPT THAT ARE OPEN AND THE
CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL. BURKE
AYE BURKE AYE GROW. GROW AYE
ALLEN. ALLEN AYE BONTA.
BONTA ONLY TO.
CHU I GRAY AYE GRAY AYE MCCARTY.
PRETTY AYE MELINDA'S.
LENDERS ARE A LOW MOAN.
LEN I QUIRK YOU KNOW BIRKENAU
DEBILIS SO IT'S NINE TO ONE.
THAT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
FOUR. AND THIS DOES COME WITH A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
AND WE ARE ON IT.
TYPE DEADLINE SO.
TRY TO BE QUICK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT THIS
BILL TWENTY TO FIFTY FOUR. WILL
GREATLY ASSIST OUR DISABLED
VETERAN POPULATION.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA OFFERS A
BASIC PROPERTY TAX BENEFIT FOR
DISABLED VETERANS COULD
DISABILITY RATING ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT FROM THE US DEPARTMENT
OF VETERANS AFFAIRS.
THE CURRENT EXEMPTION FROM
PROPERTY TAXES ON THAT PART OF
THE FULL VALUE OF THE RESIDENTS
THE DOES NOT EXCEED ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THIS EXEMPTION AFFORDED TO
DISABLED VETERANS IS HELPFUL. AT
THE VETERANS PROPERTY IS A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS OR
LOWER IN VALUE.
UNFORTUNATELY HOMES ARE NOT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS OR
LOWER VALUE IN FACT.
THE AVERAGE CALIFORNIA HOME COST
FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND THAT WAS FIVE YEARS
AGO.
EACH YEAR THIS COST CONTINUES TO
RISE.
IT'S CRITICAL WE SUPPORT OUR
BRAVE VETERANS WHO HAVE
SACRIFICED THEIR LIVELIHOODS IN
SOME CASES THEIR VERY LIVES.
WHAT PROTECTING OUR COUNTRY?
FOR THESE REASONS I REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE EXEMPTION FROM
FULL PROPERTY TAX WERE VETERAN
WHO IS ONE. RATE OF ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT PERMANENTLY DISABLED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS
AFFAIRS OR THE VETERANS
UNMARRIED SURVIVING SPOUSE.
I TURN IT OVER TO SF.
REID WHO IS A OF VETERANS
ADVOCATE IF HE'S HERE I BELIEVE
HE IS.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY BROE'S
SECOND BY ALAN.
WHEN THIS IS A SPORT.
CAPTION NOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS SET READ I'M US ARMY
COMBAT VET SIR FROM.
TWO THOUSAND FOUR TO TWO
THOUSAND NINE.
ONCE IN AFGHANISTAN ONCE IN
IRAQ LE.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF OUR WORK
FOR READ GOVERNMENT RELATIONS.
TOM BEHALF OF OUR CLIENTS
AMERICAN LEGION DEPARTMENT
CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION COUNTY
VETERANS SERVICE OFFICERS.
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDERS
VETERANS COUNCIL MILITARY
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA.
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL CHAPTERS.
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY FOUR.
MANY THE SERVICE MEMBERS HAVE
BECOME UNEMPLOYABLE. DO THEIR
SERVICE TO THIS COUNTRY.
OF THE CHAIR MEMBERS KNOW OUR
STATE HAS A HIGHER.
COST OF LIVING THEN SURROUNDING
STATES.
WHICH WE MAKING EVERY. EFFORT TO
KEEP VETERANS AND OUR STATE THE
FEDERAL BENEFITS RECEIVED BY
THESE VETERANS HELPED A BENEFIT
OUR LOCAL AND STATE ECONOMIES
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONALLY THIS ISN'T SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
TENURE OQUENDO KAISER ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION WE ARE STILL
REVIEWING THE BILL BUT WE
ANTICIPATED UP OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
QUESTION ANSWER QUESTIONS FROM A
COMMITTEE.
STIRRUP THANKS MONITOR AMISH
LIKE IT TAKES TO BRING THIS BILL
FOR.
VERY NEEDED AND
LIKE US BE A CO AUTHOR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WEDNESDAY.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS MISTER
RIGHT.
ALL OUR SECOND THOSE COMMENTS AT
THE H. BRING GO FORWARD I'VE
WORKED.
AS YOU MAY BE AWARE ON SEVERAL
PIECES LEGISLATION OVER THE LAST
COUPLE SESSIONS TRYING TO.
INCREASED BENEFITS FOR VETERANS
WE HAVE SOME OF THE.
LOWEST BENEFITS ARE IN ALL
FIFTY STATES AND A LOT OF WORK
IS A.
NEEDED TO BE DONE AND I'D ALSO
LIKE BECAUSE THERE ARE TO
MEASURE A FEW DOES SO I HAVE TO
OF COURSE THANK YOU.
MISTER BONTA.
THANK YOU SO LACKEY FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD ARE THERE ANY
OTHER CATEGORIES OF CALIFORNIANS
WHO RECEIVE A SIMILAR BENEFIT AS
PROPOSED IN THIS BILL.
OR ONLY IS A SORT OF A AND A
NEW.
I HAVE FOR THE FIRST TIME
BENEFIT BEING OFFERED.
I BELIEVE IT'S THE FIRST TIME.
THANK YOU.
MISTER ALAN I STILL ENJOY A
COMMENT FOR THE RECORD.
WE SEE ANOTHER GROUP COME OVER
IN OPPOSITION THEY'VE OPPOSED A
NUMBER OF BILLS SAY THE NAME OF
THE GROUP IS THE CALIFORNIA TAX
REFORM ASSOCIATION.
YEAH LET THE RECORD STATE VERY
CLEARLY.
THAT ONE WOULD IMAGINE THAT A
TAX REFORM ASSOCIATION WOULD BE
ALL IN FAVOR OF REFORMING TAXES
AND LOWERING THEM IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE WE DO PAY
AMONG THE VERY HIGHEST TAX IN
THE NATION. THE HIGH SALES TAX
HIKES PERSONAL INCOME TAX AS YOU
WELL KNOW AMONG THE HIGHEST GAS
TAX NOT AMONG THE HIGHEST
CORPORATE TAXES AS WELL WE'VE
SEEN A NUMBER OF TAX BREAKS COME
THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE TODAY.
AND ALSO BREAKS TO SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS AND AT EVERY
JUNCTURE THIS CALIFORNIA TAX
REFORM ASSOCIATION HAS BEEN
ADVOCATING FOR ANYTHING BUT
REFORM THEY'VE ADVOCATING FOR
HIGHER TAXES.
SO I THINK THAT THIS ASSOCIATION
IS TO RENAME ITSELF TO YOU ARE
PERHAPS THE THE TAX. YET IS
STATUS QUO ASSOCIATION OR THE
TAX RAISING.
ASSOCIATION
THIS THE THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
KIND OF TRUTH HERE.
AND THERE'S NINE IN YOUR NAME
SO I DIDN'T REALLY HAVE AS WE
WATCHING THIS IF YOU SEEN FROM
THE CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION REALIZE AT EVERY
POINT THAT I HAVE SEEN THEM NOT
ONLY TODAY BUT IN EVERY OTHER
COMMITTEE THE PARTICIPATING IN.
THE OF ADVOCATE FOR HIGHER TAXES
ON CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU.
.
DOCTOR QUIRK.
ALL JUST SAY I RESPECT THE TAX
REFORM ASSOCIATION THEY ARE
TRYING TO CHANGE OUR TAX LAWS SO
THAT THEY HELP.
PEOPLE WHO ARE MOST IN NEED NOT
THE WEALTHY AND THEIR MANY OF
OUR TAX POSITIONS THAT THAT HELP
THE WEALTHY THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK  LIKE TO RESPOND
THAT BECAUSE I'M KIND OF CURIOUS
ON THAT'S THROUGH THE CHAIR I'M
PRETTY SURE MADAM CHAIR MAT MAY
PLEASE RESPOND.
YOU KNOW WE ARE DEADLINE FALL
I'M GONNA MAKE A VERY QUICK
OMEGA VERY QUICK.
NO RIGHT THIS IS NOT THIS DOT
THAT'S GOT THINK THAT ONE OF THE
COOL. HOLE IN THE RECORD STEAD
THAT LISTEN WE'RE NOT DISCUSSING
THIS DOSAGE OR TALKING ABOUT
LET'S GIVE SOME RESPECT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY AND HIS BILL AND
IT'S HARD WORK ON THIS ISSUE
MOVES THAT WILL. THINKTHAT WE
ARE DO YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND WITH THE AYE THE MOTION
TO BE DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITHOUT
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
YOU PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
BURKE.
BURKE I'VE BROUGH. BROKE BY
ALAN.
HEWSON PALIN I BONTA.
BONTA HIGH TO.
CHIU AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY. PRETTY AYE
MELINDA'S MELINDA'S I'LL AMONG.
LIMON AYE QUIRK AYE REGARD THE
BILL SO WHAT THE BILL IS OUT BUT
NOT MEMBERS BEFORE YOU LEAVE WE
HAVE ITEM NUMBER TWO ON CALL.
WHERE LIFT THE CALL ON ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY
ONE?
WELL KALIAKRA SINCE YOU.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE GRAY.
RAY I.
LOOK.
MCCARTY NOT VOTING.
TWO I WOULD DO WE WANTED YOU OUT
ON. RIGHT HAD THOSE ONE AT ON
DOING.
BUT WAIT A MINUTE OUT.
WE HAVE ANOTHER ONE.
I KNOW GOT UP OKAY.
I JUST HAVE ALL THESE PEOPLE
HERE.
ADD ONS FOR ITEM NUMBER THREE
ALLEN. ALLEN AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE CHIU BOAT SHOE I GRAY.
GRAY I.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE THE BILL'S
PAST MISTER HOLTON ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BONTA. BONTA AYE CHU.
CHU AYE GRAY. GRAY AYE.
CLASS ITEM NUMBER SIX.
OUT ON ALLEN ALLEN AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE CHU. CHU AYE GRAY.
GRAY I.
WE'RE JOINED